in ten days let's dance the Guardians  arrive that will set off the bomb  immediately try again it was May 5th I  hope you're ready it'll be here any  minute is that a rifle you don't know  what a rifle looks like it's just swords  were your thing and guns were mine but I  guess we were both doing guns now I just  didn't know that  I see it within you fear jealousy  betrayal this is our duty to cleanse the  universe of this weirdness you know they  told me you people were conceited douche  bags but that isn't true at all  dude I'm using my wrong  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so it's saving the galaxy again we're  really gonna be able to jack up our  price it for two-time galaxy savers  [Music]  [Applause]  sometimes the thing you're searching for  your whole life  it's right there by your side all along  your right  [Music]  or family  so maybe her  after all these years I've found you and  who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter  [Music]  you